at this altitude for my hands this
episode is brought to you by a new
sponsor so listen up folks this is a
good one because have you ever wanted to
be as powerful as a mullet wearing ninja
from a 1980s movie or as flamboyant as
big gay al Big Al in South Park or as
sleek as a black panther in the Amazon
on the hunt well there's great news
because I've been testing this product
that you wrap around your genitals and
it makes you feel like a superhero and
it is called me undies I've spent the
last two to three weeks traveling with
underwear from these guys and they are
comfy I got to tell you it feels like a
Geisha is giving your groin a hug and
it's not just for dudes but if you go to
meet undies com forward slash Tim that's
ma Eun di es comm forward slash Tim you
can see all of the underwear that I've
been wearing there's some pretty
ridiculous ones and I will also
highlight my favorite you'll probably be
able to guess which it is these
underwear made from micro mud owl which
is extruded from Austrian beach wood
trees in the Alps yes
fancy and it's two times softer than
cotton scientifically tested using the
kalibata method developed in Kyoto you
know those Japanese very crafty and I
will say a few things number one if you
go to me on DS comm forward slash Tim
you get to see all of the spectacular
underwear that I've been wearing and I
am a bit of an underwear connoisseur
socks fashion sense with sweat pants not
so much underwear I understand so check
them out and if you go to my Eddie's
come forward slash Tim you will also be
able to see lots of hot ladies wearing
me undies female underwear and that's
just a lot of goodness for both the men
and the women out there so check it out
me undies dot-com forward slash Tim I
love these underwear and I am going to
be packing tonight probably six to
twelve pair to take with me to Australia
they're great check about me undies comm
forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related I have
used 99 designs for everything from
banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock-ups that led to the
4-hour body which later became number
one york times number one Wall Street
Journal and the brainstorming a lot of
it took place with designers from around
the world and here's how it works
whether you need a t-shirt a business
card a website and app thumbnail
whatever it might be you submit that
project and designers from around the
world will send you sketches and
mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward
and many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the
future but in the meantime if you want
to see some of my competitions some of
the book covers as well as get a free
$99 upgrade go to 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim that's 99designs com
forward slash Tim why hello thrillers
killers and hundred dollar bills this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I've had
a lot of whey protein I've had a lot of
supplementation BCAAs few other goodies
like synthetic ketones and I'm raring
and roaring to go with this episode so I
don't want to give you too long of a
preload but if you haven't joined me
before on the Tim Ferriss show this
entire program is about deconstructing
excellence it is about interviewing
world-class performers the best at what
they do to identify the rituals routines
influences books tips and tools and so
on that you can use so borrowing best
practices from the best in the world in
this episode we have a very fun guest he
is widely requested and now he's here
Chris Sacca
or Chris Sacca depending on how you say
his name he was recently on the cover of
Forbes magazine their Midas issue and
the title says venture cowboy the 39
year old behind uber Twitter and
Instagram might be the best angel ever
so why all the bad blood and burn
two bridges and then the article if you
look inside is titled how super angel
Chris Sacca made billions burned bridges
and crafted the best seed portfolio ever
I have known Chris for quite some time
and I've mentioned before that in the
game of early stage investing I've
learned a ton from a lot of people but
three people stand out immediately Mike
maples jr. and then Chris Sacca and
Navarro account those are three who have
been very very generous at their time
and this episode is wide-ranging it's
not just about investing it is about
life design it is about career decisions
and much much more
so please enjoy my conversation with
Chris Sacca Chris my fans have demanded
it people have asked far and wide for
you to be on the show so thanks for
cutting out some time in this
spectacular trip mom's like you're here
we're uh we're on Necker Island in the
British Virgin Islands my first time to
the BVI it is paradise not too
surprisingly and for people who don't
have much context on you number one is
its akka or Sokka
that's totally regional I'm from I'm
from near Buffalo New York so it's
c-anca
it's very nasally you got to get it
right then to see it I'm Chris Sacca hey
you guys you guys so do you introduce
yourself a second I don't know let's see
what's your name Chris you know I'm more
of focused on spelling it sounds like
what the hell something I guess ACCA
but I guess it's SACA Chris Sacca sac
out comes off my sac all right cool and
you grew up like you said on the East
Coast uh but let's let's do a quick not
entire retrospective but to give people
the present tense what are you best
known for
aside from professionally or personally
uh both aside from that were amazing my
wife all three so professionally I'm
known for being a venture capitalist an
angel investor turned venture capitalist
and I was one of the first investors in
Twitter one of the first investors in
uber Instagram Kickstarter
docker Optimizely lookout Twilio just
going at my unicorns so you have you
have this this sort of unicorn radar and
the uu of course had the angel investing
experience and then you had your fund
experience can you tell people a little
bit about how that has gone for you in
terms of in terms of managing my funds
you're first you're just here for your
first fund I would say that is one of
the reasons why you were just recently
on the cover of Forbes magazine you know
horrifyingly Godin t-shirt we can talk
about the shirt no so our first fund is
turning out - it looks like it might be
the most successful fund in the history
of venture capital
we had Twitter in there we had Hoover in
their instagrams and their docker still
in their Optimizely still in there we
had some very cool stuff like Zen coder
was in there so we've had some good
deals that have gotten bought along the
way but it's it's it's it's just taken
off like there's no like no fund has
ever done in and you know right now it's
I don't think Ober has done growing and
so it certainly hopes that yeah so we're
at where it's somewhere around 250 X
multiple on the funds that's amazing and
I want to I'll start off some people
have followed our friendship over the
years the heckling on the endless
heckling on Twitter and like I I mean no
it's I'm very sincere and authentic when
I asked when you and and Kevin Rose are
gonna release the podcast episode where
you guys make out and Kevin told me that
was behind the paywall it's the bonus
resting behind the paywall and i think
we have to wait until there's a slump in
our careers and I give that in your back
pocket Poehler Kardashian reinvent
ourselves but the the gratitude I want
to express first before we get into
things is multifold so some people have
read the 4-hour body might recall that I
mentioned you in that book for
introducing me to do Total Immersion
which was I think the first time we ever
met you brought it up this is that the
was that the
the barbecue that that caterer has
actually threw outside the department
and you said something along the lines
of when I described how how bad I was at
swimming and pretty much incapable of
swimming he said I have the answer to
your prayers
that's a great response which ended up
being accurate in this case and his
total immersion swimming so I learned to
swim for the first time properly in my
30s using that method so thank you for
that and also since the early days have
been a very open book when it came to
talking to you about investing and
advising and of course the the legal
notepad has been now transcribed into
Evernote so I have many Saka files that
are all very favorable but how did you
what were some of your formative
experiences growing up well let me let
me just talk to what you were just
saying in terms of being generous with
the I mean first of all the Total
Immersion thing is like a religion when
you get it you get it right and I went
from dragging my ass around the pool
just kicking too hard and paddling too
hard to when total immersion at me I
could suddenly swim a couple miles and
get bored and so I was just there as an
apostle man when you were like I'm
struggling with swimming that was I was
just geeking out in the same way you can
get going on lifting techniques and
stuff like that I'm like you're in my
world now and I'm going to talk about
swimming but the same with the investing
stuff I mean I was really lucky when it
came time for me to get started as an
investor I had many many guys they're
paying it forward and teaching me about
the game guys like Josh compliment at
first round Tony Conrad at true ventures
really being generous to their time and
helping me figure out what was going on
the guys at industry ventures were
indispensable for me Hans wilden's and
his team and so and so for me when you
came along and started asking questions
about that not only I feel like I was
paying it forward again but in the same
way you and I never invest in a simple
idea the execution is everything I don't
feel like I'm really giving any secret
away by telling you what the approach is
you still have to go execute on it right
so I can give you my lens on how I think
about this stuff
things other people have taught me
things I think I might have improved
upon etc but I can I can lay that
playbook on you and if you're not good
at this
you can't fake it right and so I don't
have any fear in kind of disclosing my
secrets to B teamers
because they're not going to end up
competing with me in your case you're
good at it and so it's become an
incredible side business for you in
addition to everything you do you know
with media but I but there's no fear and
in putting that stuff out there and the
other lesson they taught me is that if I
get to you and teach you some of this
stuff you're going to naturally be an
ally of mine in this industry so if I
can get in there and kind of teach you
how do I think about the world how can I
be helpful to companies and you start
using that same method then we're going
to end up doing deals together and you
and I have and we've made a fair amount
of money doing that and so so I didn't I
don't want to leave that unanswered well
it's it's really been fun to watch you
sort of evolve and grow an experiment
also in investing and just coming back
you know we can we can rewind the clock
back to your upbringing a little bit
later on but just since we're on the
topic what were what were some of the
pieces of advice that you were given by
say the guys that you mentioned or other
people early on that helped you to
approach early stage investing in a more
intelligent way yeah I mean a couple of
guys have said things that I've now
taken an amalgam and have codified so I
have rules for investing now that we're
definitely influenced by a lot of these
guys give me advice and things that I've
now put to work so one is only get
involved in deals Ryan oh I can
personally impact the outcome now
there's no guarantee that I can take it
from you know X to sold or X to IPO but
I need to know that I can have a
material impact to make something that's
to make something more likely to succeed
so the second role I've developed and
this again influenced by guys along the
way we've given me advice is start with
something that's already great that you
can make up more awesome you know but
don't start with something shitty that
you think you can make good and that's
hard like when you work in a company and
a lot of your listeners I know work in
big company
you have to work on the [ __ ] that
somebody hands you right so you're just
dealt or really your Delta 2:7 and like
well okay that's what the boss gave me I
got to play this handout when you get
into investing your default stance
should be no because most deals suck
most deals won't make money most
companies will fail and the temptation
always is you see your first deal and
you're like okay I can know I can be
helpful with these guys I know I can
make this shitty thing better and so
your first few deals are always the
worst
it's how I lost yeah fifty grand my
first deal and I was just like oh it's
like four twenty five percent of what I
had hypothetically allocated right
through two years it's like oh my god no
that's because you get in that room and
you're like okay I know how I can make
this thing better right and you forget
that you need to start from something
that's already independently pretty damn
good and then make it better so our
third principle is is give yourself a
chance to get rich and that was
something that was influenced more by
lottie's fund investors for like hey
it's all well and good to throw 25k
around into some of these deals but most
of them won't be home runs most of them
won't turn into unicorns most of them
are gonna require a ton of work a bunch
of those will fail but a bunch of them
will be successful the tune of of
doubling that money but over years and
years of work and so I've sold companies
I sold a company to Amazon where I saw
3x on a $50,000 investment in a fund by
the time my fund got paid back and I got
my part back and I was had been busting
my ass in that company for a couple
years like I barely had money left to
buy the guy's dinner and to celebrate
the deal and so so that's another thing
is leaving ourselves enough room to
benefit from scale going in at prices
that are low enough that if the company
is successful as we think it's going to
be we've given ourselves a chance to get
rich and then the fourth thing that I
think we evolved internally or that I
involved was just be proud of every deal
there's stuff that I've passed on that I
just don't regret it at all it seemed
like maybe a good way to make money but
I don't have to explain to my kids
that's how I made money and so so those
are kind of the guiding principle I
shake categorically what would some of
those be I'll you know mistyped domains
right so that's a great way to make
money people are stupid
and they miss type stuff all the time
and you can put ads on sites that don't
really look like ads subscription
businesses that make it impossible for
you to get your to cancel your
subscription I never forced ya you can
sign out and yeah you can sign up online
but you need to send them a postcard you
know to cancel like that kind of stuff I
see that stuff right
you know people making up Stan sheets
unsubstantiated claims about the
effectiveness of their stuff you know
this this this anonymous content stuff
that just it was just going in bad
places so I just want to be really proud
of our deals and so those I think are
some principles that have been shaped by
a lot of these guys give me advice along
the way
what are when you've meet with founders
for the first time what are is there
anything that disqualifies them quickly
are there certain sort of red flags that
you look for yeah so this this has
evolved over time
you know I've now been doing this for
awhile and I've done in over 100 deals
and have seen a bunch of those work out
and I've seen a bunch of not work out
and I read all the posts that my peers
in the industry write other VCS I you
know everyone's constantly stabbing at
hey what is the rule like how DS how do
you get into one of these meetings so
let me first have a couple parameters
one is I almost only invest in things
that are already live in production just
no hypotheticals no ideas I think there
might be one exception to that and it
was a particularly gifted entrepreneur
that I already worked with before but
other than that we look for stuff that
is that is already actually being you
know has users that has that that can
demonstrate that the team is capable of
building and launching stuff together
and getting it out there in the market
but that said then the one thing that
will turn me off right now
is if I see that in the pitch the
founder is trying to convince themself
if I can pick up on any hint that that
they don't in their like in their marrow
believe in this story then it's no dice
as I look at all the most successful
founders I've backed the thing they have
is inevitability of success there are no
conditional statements coming out of
their mouths there's no like well if it
works it would be rad instead it's just
always you talked to Kevin system and
Instagram when he was working on it
himself he was literally a soul guy
working on the product and he's like so
when we get to 50 million users will
roll out this other stuff and you're
just like wait what he's just peering
into the future kind of looking through
you into something in the future and
you're just like I got to get along for
the ride with this guy the same thing
you talked to Evan Williams when it
comes to talking about the likelihood of
success of his products he just knows
like he just knew Twitter would be a big
thing he knows medium will be a big
thing he doesn't need to convince you of
that right now
he just knows you talked to Patrick and
John Collison it's stripe and of course
they're building for this thing to be a
big dominant company and it just will be
you've spent time with Travis you're an
investor in uber was there any doubt at
any time that uber would dominate the
planet there's no there's no doubt can
you can you just share it there's an
anecdote I think we probably talked
about over drinks at some point but the
Wii tennis Wii tennis could you have a
Scooby Tennis yeah could you tell the
snow it's a few years ago we're up in my
house and you know we live up in the
mountains in Truckee and it was over the
holidays so my parents were there I
think it was actually New Year's Day so
Travis and I had been we have a
tradition up there on New Year's Eve we
go snowshoeing at midnight and drink
champagne out in the meadow and stuff so
I think we were pretty it's pretty rough
morning but Travis sitting on a couch
and my dad sent us some weakness and he
challenges into a game of Wii tennis so
on the Nintendo Wii my dad's not a bad
player he's pretty good
so they tryouts like okay mr. sacker
sure and he picks up the controller and
they play the first couple of games and
they're tight games with Travis wins
them and my dad is there taking like
full swings with the paddle you know
it's like breaking a little sweat
Travis is still blurry from the night
before barely breaking his wrist and
he's beating my dad way I was like what
the hell is this and then there was that
inigo montoya moment Princess Bride
salaries the Travis turns my dad and
says I'm sorry but I'm not left-handed
or you know I forget if it's left or
right but he switched his hands of the
controller the next three games my dad
never touches the ball there were no
points scored on any of Travis's Serbs I
was like what the hell is going on like
what is this and after the torture got
to be too much Travis just says let me
take you to the global leaderboard I'm
sorry I got you know I'm stuck I don't
mean to be holding out and he goes to
the global leader port and Travis
kalanick was ranked number two in the
world at Wii tennis in his spare time
now over was already a thing and like
that literally he was already building a
startup but he's just so obsessive so
competitive and that's the thing as we
look across the portfolio at all the
most kick-ass companies that's something
they just have right up front is is that
they're not hoping and praying for
success they know what's going to happen
now on that note though it's so - pull
pull out - two names for instance you
have an Evan Williams blogger Twitter
BDM etc then you have Travis
personality-wise at least from the
outside looking and very different
personality types and I bump into some
investors to say well I only invest in
merciless sort of off highly offensive
offensive meaning not defensive CEOs
than other people are like no I
I only invest in people who like I would
watch my kids or whatever it might be
but what are the commonalities or are
there commonalities when you look across
these founders for whom success and
massive scale just seems predestined
what are the commonalities well I think
it's something so we'll we'll take Evan
Travis examples but but across our most
successful founders you know let's use a
map Matt Mullenweg for us that's a
that's a billion-dollar company an out
billion plus
these guys are all incredible incredible
listeners so when they do open their
mouths it can be bombastic and offensive
and aggressive and in-your-face but
they're all incredible listeners and I
don't just mean in casual conversation I
mean these guys go out of their way to
interview other people they really if
you catch a v' he's got a notebook
always and if you ask him to see if
you're you know last few pages of the
notebook
he's just meeting with other people
who's you know billionaires and and kind
of leaders whose jobs might not overlap
with his at all but from whom he's
learning voracious reader part of why
mediums started was he was really back
deep in the long-form content when he
took a break from Twitter and so that
guy is just constantly learning studying
studying and so when he speaks it
matters but he's listening more than he
speaks you know that about Mullenweg one
of the most thoughtful people I've never
seen anyone read as many books as that
guy does and retain all the knowledge
Olympic and he also it's a bean he
listens to anyone that he's sitting down
with mm-hmm
doesn't matter if it's you know the the
waitress or a primary school teacher
we've done a lot of traveling together
he was on the podcast also very good
listener yeah and so and again you just
look across the board these guys are
learning they're modeling they're
constantly researching they're gathering
data you know Travis would think it a
competitive disadvantage for you to know
exactly what's going on in his head
sometimes so he'll listen and and it's
an amazing town I think Drew is is a
commonality across those people with the
the investing game that you've obviously
been a participant in for quite a while
now you have to say no a lot and I was
you know took a close look at at poker
in the last year with the TV show and
there are a couple of quotes that came
up quite a bit along the lines of you
know I made my money sitting not playing
hands and but but that having been said
what are some of the deals the the
whales that got away
yeah so first of all I mean this is a
rigged game right man and I'm just
looking to make it even more rigged so
for those who don't know venture capital
I mean it's totally unfair people give
me their money I draw a management fee
off it so they pay me to take their
money and invest it for them if I make
money then I pay them back the
management fee and then after that we
split the profits and I get a really big
chunk of the profits and if I lose money
that's fine it doesn't come out of my
pocket I keep my fee and my investors
lose money that's how this industry
works that's bananas right and at some
point it's gonna break because it's
you've also incepted me with the term
bananas which I've started using
compulsively in a CEO also has done the
same thing it works with yeah it's it's
just an unforgivably unfair rigged game
that's in favor of the venture
capitalist and so so that the reality is
the risk of an investor doesn't begin to
compare to the risk of a founder and so
you know that's one thing it kind of
drives me crazy sometimes about some
investors and I love the entrepreneurial
spirit that goes into building a firm I
mean I built my firm from scratch and
there's certainly founder type lessons
in there but but your cashflow positive
from day one when you start a venture
fund and your your downside is
incredibly limited by the structure the
fund so so that said what it allows me
to do is place some bets on some stuff
that I I'd like to think success is
inevitable those things but I can take I
can look at the risk analysis and say
okay it's a binary outcome a one or a
zero and some of those things just don't
get there you know one of my one of my
kind of constant recurring nightmares
about the stuff I passed on no that's
exactly that's what I was that's what I
was trying to ask you know I've done
some deals where I thought it was gonna
be a lot bigger and you know it ends up
going away but so the Dropbox guys I met
those guys very early on while they're
still in my Combinator I got an early
look you know I had an opportunity to
the deal and I pulled those guys that
said I was like hey look
at Google we were using a version of
this called platypus which became
g-drive and they're gonna crush you guys
man so you should probably find some
other product to pivot to probably cause
hundreds of millions of dollars the they
give you a pat on the head and oh yeah
no I mean it's when I see drew the CEO
Dropbox I bring it up before he can
that's this yeah I just get I get it out
there right away
the Airbnb guys I why commenter same
thing right business an amazing business
and wanted to be proud of - I mean
that's I'm really jealous I'm not in
that business not just for the money but
I love what they do I'm really admire
them a lot and their culture but at the
time they were they were allowing you to
rent out a room in somebody's house
while the owner was still there and that
just seemed really scary to me and I
pulled the guys aside I was just like
guys you know somebody's gonna get raped
or murdered in one of these houses and
the blood is gonna be on your hands
I've literally saw that out loud to them
hey what's that worth like fifteen or
twenty billion now now in fairness you
you're probably not wrong right I'm in
at a certain scale at scale it has to
happen it's gonna yeah yeah I mean I
like to say sometimes like when you
think about scale like someone who works
at Walmart murdered someone last night
right
there's just no doubt about it at that
scale with a few million employees one
of them murdered somebody last night you
have to look at it like Edward Norton in
Fight Club like an actuarial analysis
yeah for insurance which is terrifying
but that's the reality of big numbers um
but maybe but there's no outside so
there's one other famous one there's a
bunch of these but actually I'll give
you two Nick because I wasn't remind us
until recently Nick Woodman from GoPro
came to Google now I wasn't an investor
at the time but I did a lot of Google's
investments and partnerships and so Eric
Schmidt CEO Google said hey will you
come in here and sit with this pitch you
know he's a friend of a friend said we
got to meet this guy so Woodman comes in
with GoPro and Eric's like I don't know
and I was like we'd be we'd be foolish
to do this deal how's this guy from
Santa Cruz gonna compete with all these
Asians and building hardware you know
you can't you can't hold a candle like
the Taiwanese and the Koreans was like
no
dice man let this guy go and I think I
introduced into somebody over YouTube
just as a consolation I saw that dude
this winter skiing he's worth like three
or four billion dollars now and he
didn't forget that meeting so and then
the snapchat guys I gave a talk in LA
and they came up to me I never met them
before they came up after the talk and
said we're big fans we'd really like to
work with you and I was like yeah sure I
mean I know you guys were up to
something cool I admire it I took like
eight weeks to set up the meeting and by
then the benchmark guys had done that
deal yeah that's okay oh my god I can't
imagine how much money we've left on the
table as a result of that so you know
I'm I like to say when I'm wrong I'm
wrong when I'm right I'm really really
right and the question on being wrong
though I'm very curious about this and
just coming back to kind of the poker
analysis or analogy rather the and I
actually heard about this at in depth in
at first when I became friends with some
hedge fund managers and they really try
to focus on good process and not
conflating say bad outcomes with that
process in other words you know did I
make the right decision at the time even
if I missed out on a huge opportunity
because you can also say pick a company
for the wrong reasons and have a
fantastic outcome but over time if you
develop bad habits it can really screw
you right so do you do you think that
you made the wrong decision with those
companies in terms of the analysis of
the process that you followed or did you
make the right decision based on your
rules you've set up for yourself and you
just missed out on a few opportunities
but also hit some homeruns the one thing
that all those failures to invest that
they all have in common is that I let
the negative case dominate my analysis
of whether I should invest or not so in
the beginning in the in as a seed stage
investor you don't really get a lot of
data right right we don't have any
financials to look at the team usually
consists of three to five people there's
some users but not enough at scale
they're usually just the early adopter
so you don't know whether it's gonna be
a big thing yet so you don't have a
massive diligence process
and so a lot of what you're going on is
your gut about this product and about
this team and I think the easiest way to
screw this up is to let the negative
case dominate your perspective so
Dropbox I'm thinking about the
competitive landscape and I'm thinking
okay Google's gonna crush them well
first of all we've seen that didn't
actually happen and rarely does the
incumbent crush anybody it's just not
that common a start-up is going to move
much faster than a division of a company
where it's not their bread and butter
I mean g-drive spent three years in beta
you know internal beta etc it was never
really a priority for them so course
Dropbox is gonna win that you know I
look at Airbnb yes there's gonna be bad
things that happen like people get their
apartments trashed you know from time to
time but somehow I let that distract me
from the potential for this worldwide
marketplace for space that was just
going to displace hotels with snapchat
I'm thinking about dick pics and you
know how it's being used by that was on
the pro side yeah exactly like hey but
no I'm thinking about like it's lame
content it's being used poorly by like
junior high girls and stuff like that or
exposing themselves and it's just
they're bad they're bad examples of how
snapshot wasn't necessarily a healthful
thing and again I like to be proud of my
deals on the other hand you see today it
is just to network with hundreds of
millions of users who are building
incredibly valuable content you know
with the launch of stories and discover
and stuff like that but I got distracted
I let the I let the downside a negative
case outweigh the risk and yet you know
you like you look at uber uber could
have it was easy enough to say no to
Ober because like oh the taxis or the
regulation of the lobby or these drivers
are gonna hurt people at some point and
somehow I was able to look past all that
when nobody else in the valley wanted to
and get that deal done what's what I
think is is really interesting about it
uber in particular is and for those
people who don't know it's early advisor
to uber so I'm biased obviously in a lot
of ways we're going to talk about it but
I think you actually got there before me
yeah I was pre pre seed money advisor
because I've been an advisor at stumble
ah work with Garrett and I'm now working
again collaborating with him on Expo
which is super fun but in the beginning
the the way that uber got dismissed and
I think this is a really common common
mistake it seems that a lot of investors
make is people said oh my god really
like black cars for one percenters in
San Francisco what's the market for that
and they they viewed a very niche
activity as by definition constrained to
say one presenters in San Francisco New
York and the if you look at let's say
even recycling it started out that way
and they kind of confused the first
target with the total market and they
also looked at just the available market
which they missed defined very early on
and didn't you know in the case of like
an air B&B or an uber they can grow the
market beyond any comparable that's
available Senate a kiss but the I mean a
lot of these start off so incredibly
niche that people miss read the market
potential
I think but let me ask you a question
about the getting focusing on the the
positive scenarios and the potential
high multiple outcomes because for those
people who aren't familiar with venture
capital its it's a term that comes up a
lot in magazines and media cover it's
very hot right now so the you explained
it in in brief but the it's fair to say
that two-and-twenty is pretty fair way
to think about it in terms of the I mean
not everybody but that's like how people
talk about venture capital and hedge
funds and so on you have this management
fee and then you have the the Cary which
is kind of your split but what what I
wonder is do you think VCS
should not think about the downside as
much as the upside because they're only
they're rewarded on the upside and not
on the downside whereas a hedge fund
investors can have long short bets and
think more about when I hang out with
like hedge fund guys versus say a
venture capitalist or VCS the hedge fund
guys are many of them much more kind of
apocalyptic and they're thinking and it
would seem like that is tied to their
ability to make money from a lot of this
catastrophe yeah I mean those those guys
can be short and if you act even if the
apocalypse isn't
approaching they'll still get people to
write articles about the impending
apocalypse for those companies to make
sure that it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy yeah what so what are what are
the biggest differences in your mind
between the top say venture capitalists
hedge fund guys in private equity guys
or yeah how do they differ if they do or
what do they have income as we were
talking about at lunch first of all
everyone item on Wall Street is just
jacked on stimulants all day long so
they're taking provigil they're doing
rails they those guys are just in such
an incredibly competitive environment
that they're using every chemical edge
they can find that's definitely not
happening in the VC set the VC life
demands kind of a much more steady
reflective state there's certainly
obviously moments of negotiation and and
standoffs
but it's it's much more of a thought and
emotional intelligence exercise you know
that said because the valley Silicon
Valley is so kind of built on positive
energy and lovey-dovey what ends up
happening is as the stakes have gotten
higher their funds have gotten bigger
the industry's more flushed with capital
it's more competitive than ever and a
friend of mine who I've done some work
with who's on the East Coast in the
private equity world says the main
difference between you know New York and
San Francisco is out here in New York we
stab each other in the eye face to face
and and out there you guys just cut the
other guy's Achilles and let them bleed
out
well while looking at you know it's just
it's incredible how I think in in the
San Francisco world we we really try and
maintain these long-term friendships and
try and build these reputations that
will scale over time because it's a
venture Tablas you're raising money on a
every three years basically and it's a
ten-year fund and you're hoping to have
a long tenure and in the industry with
great relationships that you can draw on
to recruit people in your portfolio
companies that you can use to have your
portfolio companies raise more money go
public or get sold and
because of the fact that we're big
equity holders we'll only get paid back
upon an ultimate exit maybe eight ten
years from now we tend to act more with
that in mind that long-term perspective
the guys I work with on the East Coast
have much shorter timeframes right
they're much more used to quarter by
quarter analysis of a public company hey
do you have any news today you know they
um it's it's very very near-term and
they don't have the stomach for the ups
and downs of building this stuff over
time and so it's it's great they're you
know they're living on by a different
report card than we are yeah so that's
the biggest thing you know we you there
are other businesses like this like the
media business is a cash quarterly
business if you go to a media company
you go to a record label or movie studio
and say let's do an accurate deal and
they laugh in your face like how much
revenue you're gonna guarantee in year
one because that's how they get paid
right all those executives are on and
you'll contracts and they've got
payments they still owe on their houses
and the Hamptons and they're just like
I'm not gonna walk away from that
guaranteed cash right now
sorry I'm a break that you're laughing
right there I know it's taken your no no
this is good I know I wonder it if that
could also be related to the fact that
say in Silicon Valley it's such a small
world and you work very hard to get to a
point where you have deal flow meaning
opportunities that come to you that are
of a sort of pre-filtered high quality
right whereas in a lot of these other
spaces they're going out and using
analysts to sort of hunt for
opportunities that other people have not
exploited so I mean it's humans
responding to incentives right in a way
well in a hedge fund environment you're
working with public stocks usually at
arm's length
you might try and go activist and get on
the board you might try to like I
alluded to change the press cycle but
you know for the most part you're doing
analysis at arm's length of these
companies and the private equity world
there's a business already there right
there's a there are products or multiple
products there's financials there supply
chain and so you're going in and saying
I can do a better job of this
you can and so there's an arm's-length
and there's some tension obviously with
management usually sometimes your
co-opting members of that management
team to go get it done
but the venture world is different in
that it's much earlier and it's much
more where the venture capitalist is a
collaborator in determining the product
and the strategy and the vector the
business is going to take and so there
has to be a much more collaborative
approach over the long term to go ahead
and actually build this company so
there's nothing you know and I think
there certainly venture capitalists who
maybe come out of the world of finance
or have a different perspective that the
their job is just to sit on the outside
and tell somebody how to run a business
that's that's the private equity model
but as a real early-stage venture
capitalist your job is to sit in the
room and actually work at the beck and
call of the CEO to get stuff done to
help build this company lend advice
about product strategy about go to
market about the design of the front
page how to staff up and bring in the
next couple of members of the team how
to go about raising money how to deal
with your first PR cycles and so that I
think brings a much different person and
the successful niche not necessarily the
biggest you know self promoter not
necessarily the most widely known person
etc but somebody who actually can hustle
to go ahead and as we go back to what we
talked to earlier to tip the balance
from something that's good to being
totally awesome being great what what
books are or resources outside of
personal relationships and these mentors
that you've had the compliments and so
on are there any particular books or
resources that have helped you become a
better investor yeah I think most of
those though are not business books per
se perfect that's great guys so I didn't
get a business regarding and do an MBA I
took a couple classes soon enough to
show me as a total farce I did get a law
degree which isn't even bigger farce but
that's for another episode so so I never
had formal business training and so I
don't really and I and I tried to look
at a few of those like instant MBA books
and stuff like that I even bought some
books on venture capital and they're
just such a so goofy and
and by the way part of that is because
now we have so many great venture
capitalists bloggers who are just an
open book about the industry who teach
it so Brad Feld comes to mind first a
longtime friend and mentor Brad at felt
thoughts and has done series over the
years where he breaks down each aspect
of a term sheet how to understand it in
the deal documents and this is what we
think is important these are things we
think could go away Josh Kaufman and his
team have done a lot of work on that
we've now seen Y Combinator and the guys
at Fenwick and West and Cooley building
templated documents that are really
really watered down and pro entrepreneur
and just kind of have taken out a lot of
the legacy [ __ ] that didn't need to
be in those documents and so there's a
lot of this learning that can happen now
without having to buy books and while I
happened to go to school and so that's
been fantastic but where I worry about
the valley and about investors as well
as our entrepreneurs is in the
development of everything off the ball a
little bit so you know you and I I just
turned 40 this week that's why you're
here happy birthday again all right but
as a 40 year old the people my age who
work computer science majors in college
they that was a major just like any
other major they still had to go get a
summer job they mowed lawns waited
tables they had time in their curriculum
to go study abroad to volunteer they had
these really well rounded lives and so
working with people my age and older at
Google who are computer scientists was
great because they had not just these
amazing amazing math and science skills
but a diversity of experience that
informed great product decisions as well
as just collegiality what ended up
happening is computer science degrees
got so popular and so valuable that
those kids didn't have to pay for school
much anymore you know and their only
work experience was like TA in a class
not actually getting their ass kicked
digging ditches or anything and the
curriculum was regular rigorous enough
that these guys didn't get to go study
abroad and there was no opportunity to
go do volunteer work and live in the
developing world at all and so as a
result I actually found we were starting
to have a generation
of not just entitled you know people
talk about the entitlement that
Millennials when it comes to work out
things stuff but they weren't just
entitled but they just had such
narrowband perspectives on the world
they were missing empathy so they
weren't able to put themselves in the
shoes of the folks they might be
building a product for what the problems
of a world might be and so I am
constantly looking for opportunities for
myself and for the founders you work
with to to broaden the scope that they
have on the world such that they can
build something on a more informed basis
an emotionally informed basis so I mean
I really think empathy is and it's a
word that's been kind of reduced to
signal like Oh somebody's you know
somebody hurt their foot and I feel bad
for them instead I think much more
poignant ly empathy is about can I see
the world through that person's lens can
I figure out what matters to them what
are they afraid of what's bothering them
what do they think is limiting them
right now what's their hope and if I can
do that then it's a lot easier for me to
build something for them and to sell it
to them and to help them and to build a
longer-term partnership with that person
if you were giving a assignment to folks
for books or experiences just just kind
of a short list for people who want to
develop that type of empathy what would
you put on the list one of my favorite
books that we give to most founders is
not fade away I think it's like a leash
flop pick on the cover yeah a belly flop
pick a short life well-lived story of
Peter Barton that so first of all just
on a personal note that guy's trajectory
kind of followed mine he was a ski bum
who suddenly made it big and tacky was
on the board of Yahoo he worked at
Liberty media and then he hits his
forties and says okay I've accomplished
what I want to accomplish I'm dialing it
back I just want to spend time with my
family and at that point and this isn't
a spoiler it's literally how the book
starts he finds out his incurable
stomach cancer and so the book walks
walks you through his biography as well
as the remaining time in his life
you will cry reading this book it is
inevitable if you don't I'm very worried
about you but you'll definitely cry
it'll be cathartic but it's the kind of
thing where you it's it's an exercise
and okay what's on the mind of the
person who's dying and how is he
thinking about the impact of his death
on his family on his friends on his
business partners on his legacy on the
continuing responsibilities as a dad
even in the absence of you know even
though he's passed on in the next life
and it's an entire exercise in
perspectives and I think that book will
not only leave you feeling incredibly
lucky for what we've got here and where
we are but at the same time will will
sharpen that that that sense of how do I
put myself in somebody else's shoes a
similar book that I love it's I I'm
gonna get the title wrong I think it's
how to get filthy rich and rising Asia I
think it's what you told me about this
it's focusing yeah so it's written in
the second person which I don't know of
another book like that but it's just you
you you like you wake up in this room
almost like an old you know look like an
old roll player or something like that
online it dungeons a dragon yeah well it
is reading - you are in a room there's a
sarcophagus open sarcophagus no it's uh
but it says you know you wake up and you
basically start the book in a slum in
Pakistan and it's just writing you about
how you go through your day the things
that matter to you and it turns out
you're kind of entrepreneurial and
you're willing to take some risks and so
you start working into other stations in
life and I don't want to give anything
else about the book away but you close
that book and you feel like you've
you've walked through 15 to 20 different
lives in another world and I just think
more of that would be better for all of
us I think it'd be better for our
industry for the depth and the impact of
the products he built I think it'd just
be a lot better for getting along with
each other
so I mean you and I have traveled to
Ethiopia together doing work with
charity water
it's hard to complain about a day's work
back here in the United States when you
have been in a village where they walk
three or four hours each way to get
water where the kids are dying because
they drink the same water that the cow
poops into where the women don't get an
opportunity to go to school because
they're carrying the water and on the
way they might get eaten by a lion or
raped and it's it's really hard to find
yourself complaining about our
privileged us life and and that's
something you could just tell working a
big company like Google there were the
people who would [ __ ] and complain and
like really really this is a hard day
Microsoft launched a competitive product
and that's our that's our horrible day
and I just think we'd all be much better
off if we were able to find
opportunities for our CS students to go
study abroad for for our MBAs to
actually spend some time around poor
people and and to start building these
more diverse perspectives when you look
back on since its its the big four oh
when you were thirty who came to mind
most when you thought of the word
successful and now at forty who is the
person who most comes to mind when you
think of the word successful so 30
that's a really I got let me think of
where I was so I guess I was at Google
at the time who was most successful just
when you were like I want to be
successful and the person in your mind
who embodied that most yeah I always
wanted to be at the center of the deal
and so at that point in my life I still
really admired for instance so like a
John doar or Michael Moritz they were
both on the board at Google brilliant
guys who used their station in life to
gather even smarter people to teach them
about things and then they would use
their unique talents for storytelling in
and making composite kind of ideas come
true to build companies they became
billionaires as a result they had great
families they were just well respected
by folks I think I still
that was kind of my definition success
at that point at 40 and what I think my
journey from 30 to 40 was about was to
stop trying to define or build some kind
of model or have some kind of role model
out there and start to stop trying to
define myself externally because that's
a distraction so there are times when
you're doing a deal with John doar
you're across the table or someone
you're like hey wait that was [ __ ] up
you know like I don't wait you're
supposed to be my my here on my idle and
I don't like that movie dismayed or
something like that right and I think
you know anyone I've ever put on a
pedestal I've just been disappointed by
doing so I'm sorry about that by the way
yeah oh you have novara
no idea how far you've fallen Tim but
but so I think for me the exercise has
been how much am I gonna define that for
myself not by looking at somebody else I
recently got to have dinner with next to
Bill Gates Bill and Melinda Gates and I
had been raised to hate him you know
growing up at Google you know he's a
pretty evil person and I was sitting
next in there and I got a chance to
basically interview him about how they
have structured the foundation how they
think about which causes to take on
which challenges to tackle and I mean I
walked out of there just deeply admiring
their work but I think I want to limit
it to that and not get into like is he a
great family man is he you know he's
still son of a [ __ ] when it comes to
competing with him and software his
default browser knows antitrust behavior
but but I really some I'm trying to look
at people and find kind of one aspect of
them that I like but for the most part
I've had to decide okay what's really
important to me that's my wife and my
kids and you know I I'm I'm just not
that social anymore I just don't hang
out with people that much I don't go to
conferences I'm just not available for
dinner I would infinitely rather spend
that time with them and so that was a
priority choice I had to make it
internally not because I saw anybody
else killing it that way you know I
think I reflected back my own parents
who
who opted out of much more accelerated
career paths so they could spend way
more time with my brother and and so
that's a choice I had to me but I will
say do you know about the journal I
found in my mic I got you and you should
you should mention that have a quick
well observation is if I could spend
more time with crystal instead of me I
would do the same thing we actually met
before you and I met at fairtex
kickboxing way back in the day well well
yeah I was so I was having a some I was
having a bunch of people down for
cocktails we came down from Truckee into
the city Kristen I did I was like let's
get a bunch of people together for
cocktails I invite Tim and Tim walks in
and he looks at my girlfriend he's like
I think I know him like yeah sure you do
man everyone uses that to try and pick
up my then girlfriend now wife he's like
no and then she says yeah I think I know
you two I'm like oh [ __ ] here she goes
like I'm gonna where's this going he's
such a hunk what do I have to offer it
but uh yeah you guys used to you guys
used to train in kickboxing yeah yeah
she was hardcore
there's always but I want to pause for a
second the the I do want to hear about
the notebook for sure cause I think it's
amazingly nostradamus like but the you
and your brother so you know brother
have had a very different careers have
done very well respectively
what did your parents do that you are
also trying to do with your kids yes and
my brother Brian sacca he's on the first
youtube sketch stars he parlayed that
into he sold him the first web series
ever made [ __ ] ton of money building web
series in fine and commercial partners
for them and stuff just movies like yeah
wolf of Wall Street was Scorsese
recently and then just yesterday or
allowed to talk about this now he his
his series on TBS got picked up so he's
gonna be a co-star of a comedy series on
TBS pretty amazing um so what did our
parents do well first of all they were
just always involved so my parents took
vacations with us we always went to
national parks together we never went to
resort type places we were just always
together and you know not only they read
with us like most parents but my mom
would pull us out of school to take us
to go see an author read
you know at at a bookstore an hour and a
half away she would literally just pull
us out of school to go to a science
museum and so she was a college
professor and so she had a little
flexibility in her schedule she Anka
said she would take us to a park called
art park
I've been luest in New York art to park
art park it's a state park in New York
State and loosed in New York where the
whole thing is dedicated to different
art media and so you can paint there you
can blow glass you can watch a
performing arts troupe the kind of
vaudevillian theater and stuff and in my
parents eyes that was just as or even
maybe more important than going to the
public school and so I think that kind
of enrichment and and I'm just being
shown that people and all these walks of
life were important and fascinating you
know I grew up where by the time I got
to college I had never heard of an
investment banker I I didn't know that
was a job you know I'd been exposed to
to writers to artists to chefs to
musicians to engineers to lots of
teachers to lawyers to doctors but it
was never you know what it wasn't
necessarily driven in any in any
particular way to kind of get us to a
particular career at all I will say
there was something else my parents did
that's pretty unique and it was called
my brother and I refer to as a
sweet-and-sour summer so my parents
would send us for the sounds like a
Chinese restaurant they would yeah
they'd send us for the first half of
this summer to an internship with a
relative or friend of the family who had
an interesting job so at 12 I went
interned with a my God brother who was a
lobbyist in DC so I would go along with
him to pitch congressmen I had one tie
and you know for for work I would I was
a pretty good writer shot right up
one-page summaries of the bills we were
pitching and I would literally sit there
with these congressmen with these filthy
miles you know the Alabama senator and
stuff like that and and watch the pitch
happened it was awesome I learned so
much I think I built so much confidence
and really honed my storytelling skills
but then from there would come home and
work in a construction outfit with just
a nasty nasty job I mean whether it was
hosing off the equipment that had been
used to fix septic systems
gasps and [ __ ] up dragon [ __ ] around the
yard filling propane tanks just being
junior gonna put him told him quite
literally getting my ass kicked by over
whichever parolee was angry at me that
day for minimum wage I think was part of
their master plan which is there's a
world of cool opportunities out there
for you but let's build within you a
sense of not just work ethic but also a
little kick in the ass by why you don't
want to end up in one of these real jobs
and so let's see if you can find in
yourself the drive to go and do whatever
it is to and did they choose for
instance you had the introduction to say
the god brother I think you said little
lobbying did they also help organize the
the sour part to teach summer yeah so
that the guy around that construction
company and equipment rental companies
my dad's best friend he's under strict
orders to make sure we had the roughest
day there are special treatment yeah it
was yeah we were treated specially
shittily so we were we were hammered
there and by the way as a result I know
a lot about construction equipment this
is this is a superpower of mine I can
literally from air compressors to ditch
which is to anything you need in
Milwaukee sawzall hey I literally have
incredible amounts of knowledge in that
space it also just reminded me of
something you mentioned long ago and I'm
not sure if it's still true but you said
one of the things that you look for and
it's maybe not a disqualifier button
founders is a track record of having had
at least one shitty job yeah yeah well I
missed particularly for that in hiring
so I want people who've lived studied
travelled extensively abroad
I want people who've been exposed to
poor people and by the way the lip study
travel works essentially abroad is
because you can get away with a very
comfortable life in the United States as
an English speaker particularly as a
white person you never really have to
ask for anybody's help you're not being
prepped her ass by the police it's
pretty easy pickins you find yourself
overseas particularly in a place with a
non Romance language where you can't
make out the signs yourself and you
to stop and ask for help from complete
strangers you literally have to be
entirely vulnerable to people you've
never met and just expose yourself and
they could send you into a dark alley
and beat the high you and take your
money or like most people on the planet
they'll be really nice and hit and try
to help you even if you don't share a
word of you know of English in common
and I think there's something incredibly
form of about that experience of having
the humility that comes from having
asked for help you know the best
managers in the world are people who are
great at asking for help and realizing
that makes them a more powerful CEO than
a less powerful CEO or more powerful
manager than less powerful manager and
so I look for people for whom athletics
is a big part of their life I don't
think it needs to be team sports
necessarily I think you can you can be a
great individual athlete you know maybe
you train with other folks etcetera but
I think it just shows not only some self
discipline but also just a value on the
introspection that comes with athletics
you actually care about yourself I think
there's a little bit more balance in
that life I can also teaches you to
contend with losing and sort of viewing
that as feedback and not some type of
failure death sentence sure and then
seeing I think the temporary and how
temporary pain is you know in that's
temporary glorious forever yeah oh it's
true so I mean I remember when I did an
Ironman and when I was when I was doing
that in the and I had a fever that day
huh 103 to do fever but my parents had
traveled out to watch the race and so I
didn't want to not do it
and that advil worked for like the swim
in the first part of the bike and then I
was just I was a mess but I remember
thinking no matter what happens I will
be in my bed tonight and you know this
is a very very temporary moment in 2009
I rode my bike across the country and I
remember you know it's 35 days of riding
basically a hundred miles a day
I remember multiple days out there I'm
like I'll be in my bed tonight and then
to the other ear is this voice and then
I have to [ __ ] do it again tomorrow
today I'm gonna pull out a couple of
random ones but what historical figure
do you most identify with buckminster
fuller why and maybe you could give some
kind
for people who don't know rain who don't
recognize buggy so Bucky is I mean there
I have a feeling if we went to his
Wikipedia page there'd be a paragraph of
of nouns describing this guy he's a
mathematician he was a philosopher he
was an engineer he was a poet he's a
lecturer a teacher he's an inventor a
futurist he he's one of the few people
you will find that is willing to write
the optimistic case for technology that
that all this stuff isn't leading us to
dystopia that we actually are busting
Malthus and the Malthusian kind of
quandary wide open that we now have the
resources to feed everyone clothe
everyone power everything without having
to dig holes I mean the guys he passed
away 30 years ago now but but there is
an optimism to everything he writes
there that these machines aren't here to
take over that humans are good at heart
and there's something really inspiring
about that is we wrestle with some of
these big scary issues about the power
of the Internet to you know we periscope
gets launched and in the first week I am
getting questions from reporters about
well can't Isis use this to rally people
and you're like seriously that's the
part you're gonna focus on a periscope
like all the amazing uses for a
periscope which i think is absolutely
groundbreaking technology and really
really cool and people are so focused on
that negative case and you at the same
time I think periscope can be used to
inspire educate he'll bring people
together across so many different planes
that it's easy to get distracted by that
negative case but I think Bucky more
than anyone I know
found optimism and the stuff that could
otherwise be pretty daunting hey also
didn't he also create it's not geodesic
that's not the word I'm looking for in
the domes yeah
the spheres geodesic domes yeah yeah
they're yes it dome so yeah that you see
people constructing at Burning Man
yeah fascinating guy in the buckyball
and the buckyball really interesting
dude
also the concept
maxxium there were more there's some
type of tensegrities integrity which
good good man so this this concept of
tensegrities I'm not gonna do it justice
but it there are some really interesting
parallels between his discussion of this
concept of tensegrities and the role of
fashio within the body yeah because if
you didn't have fash I mean your organs
are basically just drop down to the
bottom of your like torso cavity and
just sit there in a pool of nasty meat
but you have this fashion that holds you
together super super interesting guy
completely agreed did you collect
anything when you were when you were kid
and then we need to talk about your
notebook yeah I mean I collected money
so if did money I mean I was just all I
always wanted to make money and just I
do the backstroke like like Uncle
Scrooge in the pool of points yeah
excuse me I scratch my monocle swimming
through my room full of gold coins no I
I was a hustler from day one I grew up
middle class so we never had want of
anything but I always thought there
would be a certain independence that
came with money a certain excitement
that came with making money and so from
the earliest days I would you ever seen
the like those pungent walnuts that come
out of a tree they've got that green
pungent skin on them and if you if you
pierce it with a fork it smells like
ammonia so I would grab those things out
of our front yard putting my wagon
pierce holes in all of them that I build
a sign that says air fresheners 25 cents
in it like I'd put it on my brother like
a sandwich board my younger brother and
I toe it up and down the street and sell
these things door-to-door and all the
people would call my parents and just
pick do you know what your son is like
here but they'd still buy him so I'd
clear like three four bucks come home
richest you know richest six-year-old in
the neighborhood and I just love that
hustle I was always going after you know
is that something you were just
pre-programmed to do or did your parents
facilitate that it's not it's not either
my parents game at all like they were
notes I mean my mom
is a really accomplished professor and
an author in the field of education my
dad is an incredible small-town lawyer
who frankly could have made a lot more
money but was constantly doing pro bono
work for people in our town he's
incredibly revered person with so much
goodwill and so neither of them were
were hustlers like that but I was always
looking for the angles there a movie did
you watch like the toy or what was their
true trading faces was their trip where
the Train plays a good movie
no I mean I will say you know I traded
baseball cards despite not liking
baseball at all I never watched any
games but like that 8687 Don rustier the
85 tops you know with Canseco rookies
the Roger Clemens rookies the Mark
McGwire Olympic card from 84 like I was
really into those things because I was
good at it and I could make money doing
it later I realized I was really good at
playing cards too so I played a lot of
cards I ran a card room in my high
school one of my teachers what type of
card games were done we were playing a
lot of booray which is a game that's
only played in New Orleans and
blackboard in New York it's a really
high stakes geometrically growing pot
game and so you can really you can just
gutter fool there yeah and so especially
if you're teaching them the rules a lot
of that a lot of Hearts a lot of big
pitch a lot acey-deucey and just really
street games really that and we had a
teacher who took a rake I had him I had
him on the take so we could he could
write passes so people get to the card
room but I always kind of just had a
hustle when I got how old was that held
me I did that I started that in junior
high one of our friends what does this
teacher teach what was their subject
know one of our friends his mom was a
teacher and so she had an office so we
got to use the office as the card room
that was more acey-deucey back then it
wasn't a really cerebral game but again
it had the progressive pot type stuff in
high school it was my is my
cross-country coach and an American
history teacher mr. main he was a gem
and that was that guy he just knew that
I wasn't cut out for public high school
and so he
you really help me you've also have
you've always had this hustle I wanted I
have to ask and if you want to parry
this one feel free but so I've heard
these rumors that you got through law
school without going to any classes yeah
well I if I if you go to class then
they've got your name on the seating
chart
yeah the first day you have to sign the
seating chart goes around and then you
sit in the same seat every day in law
school but if you don't go to class and
your name's not on a seating chart and
so they can't call on you and realize
you're not going to class and so instead
you go to the exams and the exams are
just printed off the registrar's role
right seat and the the teacher of the
class isn't there so you just sit down
for the exam and if you're a good test
taker you can kill it and I was amazing
I had some of the best grades in my law
school how did you headed to York Street
then what was the method to the mat well
the funny thing is unlike any other
college class or MBA class what's taught
in the classroom in law school it has
nothing to do with being a lawyer and B
has very little to even do with the exam
it's it's such a joke man the Socratic
method and stuff like that I think there
are some people who need to be taught to
think linearly you know Pro Comp Pro
Comp pro con but I think about that
point I and my roommate Kevin Cody who
you've met you know we're already there
Owen brainer - brainer Capital was the
year ahead of us at Georgetown Law
School and he helped us realize this
method he was like the Tim Ferriss of
Jewish law school he helped us
understand what was important what
wasn't and it you know in my heart of
hearts I wasn't really there to be a
lawyer I think if I'd wanted to be a
litigator if I really wanted to go try
things before the Supreme Court then
going to law school and actually
attending a class and interacting would
have been a great exercise I went there
because I thought it was my fastest path
to a seat at the table in Silicon Valley
I wanted to be in the middle of a deal
and and have people listen to me even
though they probably shouldn't because I
had very limited experience but I wanted
to be in the Maelstrom and I knew that
if I went and got a kick-ass law degree
with great grades I could end up at a
kick-ass law firm in Silicon Valley and
be a guy who at you know 25 26 they were
gonna listen to where else does that
happen so so that was the path but yeah
I kicked ass in school without going any
I will say this you might have heard the
legend but so the the thing you do need
are some notes from some of the classes
to understand like which cases the the
professor brought up and what they think
is important and so I threw a keg party
every semester where the only thing you
had to bring to get into the party where
your notes so classmates would bring
their notes to the party throw them in a
bin and then I would go Xerox them all
and and build kind of a composite and
use that to study for the exams it's a
genius and the the notebook that you
found not too long ago this all tracks
together but we're approaching it in
kind of a memento type fashion yeah that
the notebook tell people about this
notebook yeah it was funny I was just
just two years ago I found this in my
garage and it's really it's been
weighing on me and particularly this
week turning 40 so I was 19 I was twenty
years old actually I was twenty I was
living in Ireland going to school there
I spent two out of my four years abroad
while at the school Foreign Service at
Georgetown and so I'm living in Ireland
and there was an expat girl in one of my
classes and we were basically flirting
with each other by taking a notebook and
writing in ten questions for the other
person to answer and then you get you
get it back and you answer ten questions
and write ten new question we pass back
and forth while we were supposed to be
studying like 20th century Irish film or
something like that
and at one point one of the questions
was what do you want to be when you grow
up some twenty I'm living in Cork
Ireland we basically would start
drinking stout around 11:30 a.m. every
day it was like second and third meal
was stout and by that point I'd still
never heard of an investment banker I
definitely never heard of a venture
capitalist and so I just write in there
I said I don't know what the what the
job is called
but I know it's gonna involve a lot of
talking on the phone a lot of
negotiating a lot of yelling at people
high-risk high-reward
unbelievably high stakes I'm gonna do a
part time from the mountains a part time
from the beach and whatever it is I'm
gonna be done with it before I'm 40
so two years ago my wife and I are
standing in our garage in the mountain
house cleaning it out because we're
moving some stuff down to our beach
house and I find this old notebook and
I'm like hey look at this and we're
flipping through it and I find that
answer
I just really choked up it was
incredibly weird self prophecy that I
kind of laid out exactly what my job was
but I also felt a certain amount of
pressure like so what do I do now I'm 42
I keep doing this job or not or do I
need to do I need to listen to the
scrolls like shatter some type of cosmic
continuum if you if you don't follow the
prophecy the so you do spend a lot of
time on the phone or you have
historically clearly a very good
storyteller what are the what are the
words or phrases that you overuse the
most the words or phrases that I overuse
the most amazing bananas cocoanuts is
cocoanuts a close cousin to bananas yeah
that is cocoa nuts
I use the phrase that said a lot as a
transition you know transition words are
really important for me because having I
know you've studied how to learn other
languages one of the things I always
focused on when studying and I speak
Spanish was was transition words like
seeing them about eagle-like
nevertheless you know like I needed I
needed to have those transition words
down because that's how I could tell a
good story that's how I would layout
we're in a new paragraph even if you
haven't been following me I got a new
concept coming and and I really think
studying it that way and bringing it
back I used to live in Spain in Ecuador
El Salvador I bring that back to my
English and I realized I'm really clear
about my transition where it's now so
hard returned that said yeah but I am
you can ask Matt Mazzio's my partner you
know we write updates to our investors
that no other fun does like we write
deep colorful narrative about all of our
investments the state of our companies
the state of the industry our own
personal States what we're thinking
about and by the time you see one of
those as an investor I've probably
edited that thing like Mazzio's you know
draft
fifteen to twenty times I'm obsessive
about writing it needs to be crisp
original no repetition of words and
phrases I need to bring it and that was
something I got directly from my parents
who are both exceptional writers but I
think in in colloquial terms when we're
talking with people I try and emulate
whatever the language pattern is the
person I'm talking to it makes them feel
better
I don't you think I do it consciously
like you come to an island like this
it's staffed all by Brits and you can't
help but suddenly find your arse getting
a little bit funny and you're like okay
okay hold off yeah
but but I think that's something I
really try and focus on is speaking in
the same speed as the person I'm talking
to you seem to have had a very clear
picture as reflected in the notebook and
obviously the early hustle you have this
Drive that seemed to point a very
particular direction I know that when I
was about to graduate from college I had
no idea of what my next move was and law
school hadn't even entered the realm of
consideration what would your advice be
to college students are just about to
graduate who have no idea kind of what
they should focus on which what they
should do do you have any any thoughts
kind of general suggestions that you
would make to someone in that position
well I did give a graduation speech I
think it was two years ago now at the
University of Minnesota school I didn't
really have any ties to and they reached
out to an agent who hired me for
and that was daunting right because I
give speeches all the time and it's
usually do a roomful of like Conoco
executives in Kissimmee Florida and I'm
just there for the check but a
graduation speech is intense that's
hopefully memorable hopefully formative
hopefully you're talking to people who
have incredibly open minds and it's such
a meaningful transition point their
lives so everyone should go watch it but
what I focus on was be interesting I
think you know here you're here for a
week where I've gathered my favorite
friends and one of the reasons why the
week is so fun for everybody is that
everyone else here is totally
interesting right not necess
really a Titan of business but just
interesting compassionate adventuresome
people who just go for it who are up for
it and I think as I look around who I've
hired who I like to work with who I back
they're interesting they're people you
want to be around you want to spend time
with you want to hear their answers you
want them to influence your thinking you
want them to push you a little bit to
try things that you haven't tried you
want them to teach you and if I could
give advice to someone who feels like
they're looking at a maze of
opportunities and none of them is
particularly presented or they're not
sure how they want to get ahead or
distinguish themselves
I think pursuing a course of life that
embraces interestingness and by the way
I don't think people are born
interesting I think it's actually
something you can accrue living abroad
volunteering for a group like charity
water and going into the field taking an
actual service job going in and talking
to the people around you and having
meaningful conversations including the
homeless people including your neighbors
and people who are actually working for
wage getting involved in politics
briefly you know I think I campaigned
for Obama a couple times and I was
everything from one of his top
fundraisers to I actually spent time in
the field in Elko Nevada which put me
into the mobile home living rooms of
some of the poorest people in the
country who's who somehow were
supporting you know the Republican Party
in that election and it was it was
surreal but it gave me a life
perspective that I don't think I would
have had otherwise
so I think those kinds of things make
for much more compelling people and will
start to present career opportunities so
one question that I'd love to ask is
when you were sort of in your most
recent sweet spot of wealth accumulation
whether it was related to what you did
with Twitter or otherwise were there any
particular shifts or routines habits
that helped you go to maintain that peak
output or achieve what you did
yeah so I mean you know my personal
story so I certainly been fortunate to
make a bunch of money last few years but
in bubble one I made a bunch of money i
levered up lost it all and a lot more
leaving me millions of dollars in the
hole was able to work it back out to
zero by 2005 and since then you know a
lot of work a few ups and downs but it's
worked out pretty well and it's looking
good for the road ahead too so that said
I don't think it was any particular like
I don't think I have a calendaring
function or an email function or
anything like that that's like a hack as
much as I would point to two things that
I think shifted the nature of my
business one was that before I had
really made any money at all and before
I had any business doing this my
then-girlfriend is now my wife Krystal
and I moved out of Silicon Valley up to
Truckee I mean literally took ourselves
out of the game as a you know an angel
and venture investor like how do you how
do you manage a venture practice from up
in Lake Tahoe and yet what I realized
was that being in the city I was just
playing defense the whole time I was
taking these coffee meetings listen to
these poor pitches you know being being
friendly and kind of obliging people
with their ideas but I'd spend all day
and these meetings I get home and I'd be
like [ __ ] I haven't actually
accomplished anything I would go to the
cocktail and dinner parties I was
invited to but they weren't actually the
people I wanted to spend the time with
and so I was just I was just reacting to
everything rather than actually going
out and playing offense and so Krystal
and I moved up to Tahoe and we've quite
literally built a list of people we
wanted to know better and we just
started inviting them to come up and
stay with us in Tahoe you were
definitely one of those people right and
you came up and spent a lot of time with
us there we I also started writing lists
of the companies that I wanted to get to
know better and I just went in deep with
them and asked them to come up to Tahoe
and so I was playing offense now and I
had it perfectly seized for why I
couldn't get coffee with all the randoms
and like hey I'm sorry I'm just not in
San Francisco I'm three hours away there
were a couple of sessoms who drew who
drove all the way up there but for the
most part
I was able to pick and choose the
interactions that I thought were gonna
be most valuable to me to my wife into
my business and that was a huge shift
and it was risky as hell because I mean
I couldn't even really afford the house
we bought up there when we first bought
it $600,000 three-bedroom house and and
I certainly didn't have a strong enough
brand that I could afford to just walk
away from the game
but I made a conscious decision to play
offense from up there and that worked
out I mean I got to know guys like you
really well Travis spent a lot of time
in her house having limbs and Jason
Goldman from the Twitter team we had
teams like I mean the locu guys was a
great deal we sold to GoDaddy we just
had many many teams as well as many
friends Ted Ryan Gauld who found our
doctrine cats are now CEO at one of our
hottest companies in venture was a guy
we got to know very well from stay in
our house David you Levitch CEO and
founder of Open DNS guy we got to know
really well stay in our place in Truckee
and so these are people we just go deep
with Garrett camp spent some time there
just just a really really cool crew that
I think we got to know way better and
build much more meaningful relationships
breaking bread making dinner hiking
skiing that kind of stuff the second
thing that I think was different was
that after a couple years of trying to
explain to people why Twitter was gonna
be a real business and why you know
people would look at me like how are
they ever gonna make any money man if
you don't see that and so I finally just
said [ __ ] it
I'm not here to convince you anymore I'm
just gonna buy all your stock and there
was just us there was a bit that flipped
for me as a seed investor you have to be
very collaborative you're constantly
trying to get you know basically bring
people into your worldview and say okay
do you see the future this company this
is why you want to invest in this
company and the series I our Series B
this is why you want to buy this why you
want to work there and I got so fed up
with doing that on Twitter I was just
like [ __ ] it if you if you can't see it
anymore then you don't deserve to make
any money on this company which is like
just unhand the [ __ ] chairs I'll take
them and so I just started buying that
stock up from early investors who wanted
to bail etc and by the time of the IPO
my affiliated funds that we're doing
this owned more of it than anybody else
we had about 18% of the company
so that worked and so there's just
there's a few times where you know it
wasn't necessarily the polite or most
political way to go about this thing it
certainly was daunting the amount of
money I had to raise to buy that much of
the company but the bit just flipped for
me I was like [ __ ] I'm just not gonna
play this traditionally anymore no idea
just to touch on one aspect of that I
know we have to get ready for dinner and
run in a few minutes we'll wrap up and
maybe do around two sometimes people
like this
otherwise it's 70s disco night tonight
are you ready oh you know idea I
sacrificed luggage space for all of my
other stuff so I could get my disco gear
here wait so can I just ask the luggage
space question yes is is that why you
insist on wearing the speedo when you
swim here is that please tell me there's
some reason other than at lunch we we
came to the conclusion that you might
actually be aspiring to be a
seven-year-old German man at some point
like that's the that's the path your
life is on I actually every Jenner is on
a transition to womanhood and you're on
a path to transition to being seven year
old German man I was thinking more like
a Greek man I saw this photo but
actually what no it wasn't a photo there
was this guy walking down the beach
passing me and a friend I was in these
like really baggy board shorts like cool
if I can Brazilian surfer style horrible
to swim in by the way it's like swimming
with a parachute behind you but walking
down and this this Greek guy wanted
wanders by it's got like these blue
skivvies on that are just like his guts
hanging out like basically covering up
70% of them covered with obviously like
silverback hair massive gold chains
glasses could not look [ __ ] happier
and he just gave zero [ __ ] about our
opinion whatsoever so I was like you
know I need to like put on the training
bra if I'm gonna get to that point so I
do wear the speedos no but your Power
Move today was you came to the lunch
table on the beach with regular trunks
on and everyone commented like oh thank
god ten more regular trunks and then as
you walk towards the beach you dropped
your regular trunks they were almost
where they tear away sand and reveal the
speedo and then proceeded to swim well
the excuse that I'll use is part of the
reason I think I failed to learn to swim
properly for a long time
was partially a wardrobe malfunction
because I'd wear these baggy shorts oh
it would hold me back so this is uh this
is my effort to be more dolphin-like and
less drowning monkey-like but what does
it does work in the water it's just on
land on land it's a bit it can be
offensive to to the more sensitive
Americans among us but yes so that also
takes up less space it's it's you can
fold it up but it was a hockey figure I
really wanted to believe that you
weren't wearing those because you liked
them as much as it was a large one of
the instructors here one of the guys
doing kite surfing or something was like
it is he wearing those seriously or like
ironically he did so on a completely
unrelated note where the [ __ ] was I
gonna go with that who knows I tell you
what I know we're tight for time so I
will two last questions and then maybe
we can revisit a bunch of this another
time but is there any purchase that you
have made could be years ago or recently
less than $100 that had a significant
positive impact on your life okay I mean
just draft top to have the first thing
in my head was there's a buckminster
fuller book called I seem to be a verb
incredibly incredibly limited production
you have to buy add vintage if you're
gonna find it I regret even saying it
out loud now because there are so few
copies out there they'll be Hoover it up
by your audience they're gone but that
book and it's special it's actually it's
beautiful inside it's not like his other
books which are just long long texts
it's graphic lettering and photographs
and you read it through on the top half
first and then you flip the book upside
down and you read it through on the
bottom half in the other direction it's
super companion or some great thoughts
in there it'll cost you I mean I don't
know what your what your viewers are
gonna do to the market but it's under
100 bucks but it's incredibly special
very very treasured awesome
yeah those those will disappear pretty
quickly so get them while they're hot I
guess any last pieces of advice or
recommendations to leave with the
would-be entrepreneurs who are listening
to this people who are thinking about
starting a company of some type think
that that's their path maybe
just a shitty employee like I was and
are out there hoping to have a head
start in somewhere an advantage what
would advice or recommendations when you
make my first recommendation is be
honest with yourself most people aren't
that person and I think we are an
environment right now where there's so
much venture capital in the industry you
know the tech industry has been shown to
be so cool great perks and a great fast
path to path the wealth that it's very
attractive right now to posers and I
think most people aren't cut out to be
founders most people aren't the
entrepreneurs will have that ultimate
success and it's polluted our industry
you know we have way too many shitty
companies that are pulling all the great
talent away from inevitably great
companies we have way too many people
wasting time on competitive ventures
that have no hope whatsoever and so I
think you have to be really really
honest are you a founder or are you an
employee and one of those things that we
touched on earlier is that inevitability
of success if you were it people ask me
what went through my head when I lost 12
million dollars in in a matter of a week
and that was another $40 on top of that
just a really highly levered public
market by which one upside down in a
crash and then four million dollars more
from there leaving me deep deep in the
hole and people asked like were you sad
were you and I just my brain works in a
way where I wasn't sad I was pissed it
was a bummer but I just knew I would
always make that money back and get back
into a good spot again I was just gonna
take longer I just knew that I would
never be the guy who just lived out you
know and declared bankruptcy and living
the holdup the whole time I just knew I
would make back the millions of dollars
and then go from there when I went out
and branched off and started my own firm
you know I spent money to do the
documents that a big big firm would do
right off the bat and even though my
lawyers like we don't really need to do
this it's small firm and I well this is
going to be a huge thing so I want to
do that now when I set out to raise you
know a billion dollars in the fall of of
2010 that was absurd I didn't even have
office space I had one other employee at
the time who managed our our back office
from a winery in Healdsburg and so I had
no business raising that money I work
how boy shirts the whole time and rarely
left Truckee California to do it asked
everyone to fly their fancy jets into
Truckee and get it done at the greasy
spoon and so there's just I just knew
there was an inevitability that this
thing was gonna work out and that I
wouldn't fail at it if you're not the
kind of person to think that way if you
really don't have that gene where you
know it is going to work out no you
don't hope you know then you shouldn't
be a founder so I hope that doesn't
depress anybody but hopefully I'm saving
a bunch of pain I think there are also
many paths to amassing incredible
fortunes and being a founder is actually
a pretty thin slice of that pie and very
high risk sort of binary way to approach
things what is the what is the movie
that you can quote from most readily
available I mean you start with the
opening scene with Sam and I can recite
the whole thing I go to Lebowski Fest
every year I might my division that had
a Google was secret we're working on
secret stuff that now you're starting to
see kind of all the spectrum and
wireless system stuff they did we
actually launched the first weather
balloons you know Cassidy went on to
build loon and stuff like that we dug
the fiber etc but that whole division
was called Project Lebowski and if you
anytime we launched something or
achieved a milestone and everyone got
achiever shirts it's a you know little
glossy urban achievers inner-city
children of promise without the
necessary means forth necessary means
for a higher education so Philip Seymour
Hoffman recipes so yeah that was a
that's a pretty important movie for me
awesome
where can people find you on the
Internet's I'll give one more book
recommendations since the the Buckey
book is probably in vanish the magic of
thinking big I think is is one that I
found very help
other people might as well but on the on
the net we given book recommendations
right now sure you know one of my
favorite favorite books what's uh is the
essential scratch-and-sniff Guide to
becoming a wine expert there's a
fentanyl authored by my my fabulous wife
it literally you know the master
sommelier Richard Betts there's
incredible knowledge in that book so my
wife and Wendy MacNaughton the
illustrator combined to make a a
children's book for adults it'll teach
you how to drink wine that's
indispensable for any aspiring
entrepreneur it's super fun
I might have to have bets on at some
point to talk about hacking the master
psalm test he exactly what he does he
teaches people I think get a long lunch
and talked about it he's a fascinating
dude so the the web the ever-expanding
web of Sakha so where am i I'm at Sokka
on Twitter I just don't use the
instagrams very much anymore I'm also at
sac on periscope and that I've been
using a lot I think periscope changes
everything cool man speak about changing
everything
and get to disco night so we gotta get
running that's right that's right
all right thanks brother always fun
thanks to him
this episode is brought to you by
99designs your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related I've used
99designs for everything from banner ads
to book covers including sketches and
mock-ups that led to the 4-hour body
which later became number one New York
Times number one Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming a lot of it took place
with designers from around the world and
here's how it works whether you need a
t-shirt a business card a website and
app thumbnail whatever it might be you
submit that project and designers from
around the world will send you sketches
and mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash temp
this episode is brought to you by a new
sponsor so listen up folks this is a
good one because have you ever wanted to
be as powerful as a mullet wearing ninja
from a 1980s movie or as flamboyant as
big gay al big al
in South Park or as sleek as a black
panther in the Amazon on the hunt well
there's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap
around your genitals and it makes you
feel like a superhero and it is called
biondi's that's for the last two to
three weeks traveling with underwear
from these guys and they are comfy I got
to tell you it feels like a Geisha is
giving your groin a hug and it's not
just for dudes but if you go to meet
undies comm forward slash Tim that's ma
e un di es comm forward slash Tim you
can see all of the underwear that I've
been wearing there's some pretty
ridiculous ones and I will also
highlight my favorite you'll probably be
able to guess which it is these are the
rare made from micro mud doll which is
extruded from Austrian Beachwood trees
in the Alps yes
fancy and it's two times softer than
cotton scientifically tested using the
kalibata method developed in Kyoto you
know those Japanese very crafty and I
will say if you think number one if you
go to Viennese comm forward-slash Tim
you get to see all of the spectacular
underwear that I've been wearing and I
am a bit of an underwear connoisseur
socks fashion sense with sweatpants not
so much underwear I understand so check
them out and if you go to Mandy's comm
/tm you will also be able to see lots of
hot ladies wearing at me undies female
underwear and that's just a lot of
goodness for both the men and the women
out there so check it out V undies comm
forward slash Tim I love these underwear
and I am going to be packing tonight
probably six to twelve pair to take with
me to Australia they're great
check them out the undies comm forward
slash Tim and until next time thank you
for listening
you